at the turn of the 20th century
alongside thinking about the
mechanization of physical work people
began to ponder the mechanization of
mental work one way to think about
mental works or mental labor is the
process of thinking that unfolds when
making difficult decisions which leads
one to some state of belief about
something and at the time people
wondered a complex decision making could
be mechanized and only in recent years
as anyone allowed their judgment so to
speak with regard to making decisions be
made by a computer instead of by human
beings
for example IBM the counting machines
would perform a series of calculations
and store the intermediate results
allowing it to build on previous results
to arrive at final answers in about two
weeks during which we had maybe a dozen
hours of actual calculation we did work
that would have taken a man with a desk
catheter a hundred years and immediately
people wanted flexibility in terms of
what these machines did so the ability
to change the sequence of operations
became important at first this was done
with plug boards allowing one to
reprogram the machines operation
physically and people began thinking
about how far we could take this process
embedding a sequence of mathematical and
logical operations into a mechanism so
that I can think for us Hilbert was
famous to challenging the academic
community to think about the possibility
of the mechanical process that is
automatic machines which could answer
questions for example one of his
challenges was a machine which could
answer yes or no as to whether a given
statement about mathematics is true in
such a mechanical process existing it
would completely automate the work of
all mathematicians
and at the time calculation machines
were well-known of course but thinking
machines were not and so the mechanisms
of these decision machines weren't yet
defined people were still speculated and
this is where Alan Turing enters the
story since childhood he was fascinated
with the complex mechanisms behind the
human mind
Turing simplified everyone's conceptions
of what physical form these decision
machines would actually take and in 1928
he published a historic paper that
directly addressed Hilbert's challenges
in it he imagines a machine that can do
anything any other machine might do
known as a universal machine and he
begins by imagining a machine as a human
in a box with a pencil and a stack of
paper and they are handed a book of
instructions to follow so in order to
change what this human does you must
alter the instructions in the book
that's the deep inside he had defining
behavior with symbols instead of
mechanisms this was a very clever trick
at the time so he spends the first 60%
of his paper laying out precisely how it
would work and what form these written
instructions or algorithms would take as
follows
think of each page in this book of
instructions as a single decision first
comes an observation which is the IFS
half of the conditional statement and
what the person is observing is
precisely where their pencil is pointing
in the rough work in our example it's
the first symbol of the input he calls
this their awareness so they are only
ever aware of one symbol
next they look at their instructions and
compare the symbol in their memory to a
list of possibilities in the first
column to find a match once a match is
found they move on to the second step of
the conditional statement the operation
step and what they do here is
interesting
touring observes that no matter what the
instructions are or what language they
are in they are only ever going to be
writing down symbols on the paper and or
moving their attention to some new
location and so the last column in the
table called
next state lists the next page to jump
to in this book analogy each page in the
book is a new step touring calls these
steps states of the machine and when the
next state is arrived at their current
awareness where their pencil is
currently pointing is observed again and
then they scan to find a match in the
same way once they do they follow the
sequence and then jump to the next state
and this process continues state after
state and so the process of computation
is exactly like turning pages in a book
and at each page making a decision about
what to do next based on where the
pencil is pointing on a separate page
and note that this book wouldn't be read
in the same linear order it's more like
a choose-your-own-adventure at each page
because the sequence in which they flow
through the pages or States will depend
on the input they receive but eventually
this process leads to a final state
where they write down an answer and Hulk
or stuck and they output their result
and that's how it works
notice the decision-making power of this
machine is stripped away from the human
all of the logic of their behavior is
based on how the book or algorithm is
designed what we call the program and
touring notes that all of these steps
could be done with pre-existing
technology we don't need a human as
follows
or reading symbols off the paper touring
imagines a certain scanner tag which can
move around and read individual symbols
one at a time into some form of memory
known as a read operation and then it
would move to the current state and
identify when a value in the first
column matches the scanned symbol and
once a match is found it moves over to
the operation step and lastly it also
contains a printer so it can output
symbols given by the instructions known
as print operation and that's all it
does
free move script over and over and over
again and to further simplify this
touring reminds us that the book you
provide or the algorithm and the ruffles
could all be done on one big piece of
paper and that paper could be arranged
in a long array instead of a 2d sheet
leading to his famous complication of a
machine which is essentially a roll of
paint and a scanner printer head and any
symbolic process performed by a modern
computer can be performed by this simple
machines Turing states that anything his
Universal machine can write down is what
we call computable so a computable
problem is a problem that a Turing
machine could be programmed to solve
given enough time and space to do it a
computer as we know today is a device
which can accept information in some
form store it process it and produce
answers in an acceptable read of
readable form with this definition of
course goes the injunction if we're
going to call it a computer that it must
be able also to stores on instructions
and process them from within the machine
and so touring shows that all the power
of machines are the feature computers
would be based on how you design the
instruction table instead of needing any
complex mechanism inside the machine
itself he then turns to the larger
questions in the second half of this
paper what can or can't be written down
by an automatic mechanism is there
anything that can't be computed what is
uncomputable
[Music]